bonsoir à tous alors on se connaît pas
très bien et pourtant
chose j'ai demandé à tous de fermer les
yeux alors j'en vois pas mal qui
trichent pour l'instant et malgré la
lumière je vous vois quand même
d'incarner bien les yeux s'il vous plaît
super alors maintenant je vais vous
demander de retrouver un moment dans
votre vie où vous aviez très envie de
faire quelque chose vous aviez envie
d'essayer quelque chose
et quelqu'un vous a empêché de le faire
en vous disant par exemple que l'eau
était trop petit ou que vous ne saviez
pas faire vous avez ce moment j'aimerais
que vous vous rappeliez les émotions que
vous aviez ressenti à ce moment là ce
que vous ressenti vraiment vous étiez
peut-être triste peut-être rustre et
peut-être même en colère pouvait rouvrir
les yeux et si vous aviez pu faire
autrement en ce moment là c'est de ça
qu'on va parler c'est un sujet qui est
très important pour moi et qui vous
touche tous c'est la confiance en soi la
confiance en soi c'est cette sensation
intérieur de pouvoir réaliser nos désirs
c'est elle qui nous permet d'agir c'est
sentir qu'on est capable de faire face
aux défis
c'est ce qui nous permet d'apprendre de
persévérer de faire des choix de prendre
des décisions
une vie l'étude de 1967 d'un américain
stanley coopersmith explique ce qui
induit la notion de confiance en soi
dans le chacun sait être élevé avec
amour et respect avec des consignes
claires sont contradictions sans
oppression sans contrainte et à l'
inverse avec un certain nombre de
notions sur la bonne volonté sur la
bonne nature de chacun la triste vérité
c'est que chacun d'entre nous a plus ou
moins vécu linverse de ce qui induit
cette notion de confiance en soi vous
avez tous entendu tu es trop petit tu ne
sais pas faire
tu n'as pas les compétences c'est trop
difficile pour toi dans mon activité on
me demande souvent actuellement où est
ce que je trouve l'énergie où est ce que
je trouve la motivation pour faire ça on
me dit souvent moi à ta place j'en
serais incapable
j'en serais incapable cette phrase
revient trop souvent cette phrase en
créant vous êtes une barrière que vous
mettez plus ou moins dans différents
domaines et qui vous empêche de réaliser
des choses pourtant les super héros
n'existent pas et certains font de
grandes choses dans la vie pourquoi
simplement parce qu'ils ont réalisé que
les limites qu'ils se donnent n'existe
pas alors comme toutes les histoires qui
finissent bien comment ce parasite est
une fois moi je vais vous raconter une
histoire
donc il était une fois un petit garçon
qui avait deux problèmes le premier
c'est qu'il était kill qui ne savait pas
nager
gérer c'est pas un très gros problème le
deuxième c'est qu'il est très timide
il est incapable de parler à quelqu'un
ou un inconnu au point où demandez-leur
à quelqu'un ou demander un prix un an 2
lui impossible
il va envoyer sa soeur à la place donc
on va reprendre un petit garçon qui
garçon il ya dix ans c'est les vacances
d'été
et là la chance de pouvoir partir la mer
quinze jours à la mer avec ses parents
super chouette les vacances sauf que lui
le problème c'est qu'il ne sait pas
nager premiers jours il arrive
son père et sa soeur vont jouer dans
l'eau et lui se retrouve sur la plage à
les regarder et à être incapable de les
rejoindre
alors qu'ils n'ont que de l'eau
jusqu'aux genoux il a trop peur de l'eau
et il va les regarder toute la journée
comme ça deuxième jour il retourne à la
plage
le problème on recommence il va les
revoir toute la journée sans pouvoir les
rejoindre
trois jours quatre jours kate quinze
jours comme ça vous imaginez un petit
peu la frustration de vivre quinze jours
comme ça
autour des vacances la décision elle est
prise il va convaincre ses parents de
m'inscrire au club de natation de la
ville au cours de natation de la ville
et il a la chance de n'avoir que dix ans
à 10 ans on apprend vite
donc en trois quatre mois il s'est déjà
nagé en six mois il nage aussi bien que
sa soeur et à la fin d'année il va même
il va même rentrer dans le club de
natation locales et du coup l'été
suivant au tour à la mer il ira dans
l'eau un an plus tard comme comme comme
réussite comme comme récompense d'avoir
bien franchi cette barrière
il va même intégrer le sport études et
deux ans plus tard il remet son premier
titre de champion de france seulement
quatre ans après cette plage qu'il aura
obtenu l'enfant grandit il devient
adolescent 17 ans il continue de
s'épanouir dans la nation mais son
problème de timidité subsistent et 18
ans c'est l'année du baccalauréat de
français
deux épreuves l'écrit et l'oral
évidemment avec cette timidité qui
restait le real va être difficile et ce
qui devait arriver arriva
c'est un échec impossible de dire le
moindre mot
je devrais pas détails de la note mais
je vous laisse imaginer
il passe en terminale 18 ans l'âge de la
maturité de la majorité pardon et du
baccalauréat et avec le retard un petit
peu qu'il a pris avec le français et
avec des lacunes dans certaines matières
ça s'annonce difficile et les premières
et cela tombe d'un fait mine moyenne 9
et me moyenne
c'est un pic le rattrapage 2 euros à
passer alors les enseignants regarde
quelle matière il peut choisir comment
il peut optimiser ces quelques points
qui lui manquent les 0 5 points de
moyenne qui va lui falloir pour obtenir
son baccalauréat
mais le problème cette année matière
le problème c'est qu'une fois de plus il
va falloir prendre la parole devant ces
inconnus répondre à des questions et ce
qui devait arriver arriva
c'est de nouveau un échec et il n'aura
pas se battre c'est l'horreur
alors je vous laisse imaginer un petit
peu l'été suivant après avoir ces deux
échecs ne pas avoir eu son baccalauréat
reste est en terminale lui ce même avoir
ressassé tous les autres moments dans sa
vie où il n'a pas pris la parole où il
n'a pas su parler
et pourquoi peur de dire une bêtise peur
du regard des autres
comme il tend rapport avant il s'est
décidé à trouver une solution et à
vaincre sa timidité
alors comment on fait lui se décide à
prendre un emploi d'accompagnateurs pour
de jeunes enfants où il va devoir
prendre le micro et prendre la parole
leur expliquer des choses leur donner
des consignes etc
qu'est-ce qui se passe eh bien rien du
tout tout se passe bien il par les
écoutes
parfois il dit des bêtises il se
rattrape et finalement l'année suivante
il leur assure des calories les années
qui suivent il va passer d'autres
entretiens pour des dépôts des
différentes filières d'études ou pour
des entretiens etc de travail et tout va
bien se passer
au point aujourd'hui il donne des cours
avec des amphis de deux ou trois cents
étudiants sans problème dans ces deux
étapes
il était dos au mur ils étaient dans
l'échec
il n'avait pas le choix il fallait se
battre il fallait franchir quelque chose
c'est pas toujours comme ça parfois
c'est aussi un choix d'aller plus loin
du coup je vais vous raconter une
dernière étape de la vie de cette
personne
il a 30 ans il arrêtait de nager à 18
ans voilà ça fait 12 ans il se décide à
se remettre à l'eau par plaisir trouver
un club dans le coin il se remet à nager
après quelques mois un nageur lui parle
d'un événement qui s'appelle les 24
heures de natation de lausanne c'est un
événement qui a lieu tous les ans où
toutes les personnes qui ont envie peut
venir nager la durée et la distance
qu'il souhaite et on ne sait pas
pourquoi on ne connaît pas la raison
pour laquelle c'est ça pu lui venir à
l'idée mais lui une idée folle émergent
et s'il dure l intégralité de
l'événement 24 heures
alors évidemment quand il parle de ça
son entourage les les frasques il entend
sont toujours les mêmes c'est impossible
tu te rends pas compte c'est trop
difficile personne incapable de faire ça
sauf que lui il se rappelle qu' il ya
dix ans quand il a fallu apprendre à
nager il y est arrivé quand il a fallu
vaincre sa timidité il est arrivé alors
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas il se met à
s'entraîner l'événement dans six mois
ça laisse un petit peu de temps dont qui
se prépare il s'entraîne finira en ag 1h
2h 3h 4h événement arrive c'est le
samedi il est 16 heures il se met à
l'eau finalement l'épreuve est plus
difficile que ce qu'il pense beaucoup
plus déjà parce que il ya beaucoup de
monde faut nager dans une ligne avec 20
ou 30 personnes il prend des coups le
froid ou quelques heures c'est même la
fin l'ennui c'est pas facile il va
abandonner plusieurs fois chaque fois
qu'il veut abandonner que l'idée émerge
dans sa tête il trouve l'énergie de se
relancer au point où finalement merlin
matin à 10 heures après 18 heures de
natation 18 heures dans l'eau il
franchit le record de l'épreuve 56 km
qui avait été fait 18 ans auparavant ne
savais même pas les berges envie de
sortir les organisateurs lui demande de
continuer et finalement il nagera 21h30
et parcourera 60 km vous dire il n'a pas
un aj ce jour là 24 heures non mais il
aurait peut-être plus en tout cas il a
compris qu il en était capable
et en fait à tout objectif ben il faut
faire des paliers donc c'était son
premier palier en aura d'autres
finalement il nagera les 24 heures
on peut quand même deux ans plus tard
après que quelqu'un lui ai parlé de
l'idée de nager 48 heures il se lance le
défi un petit peu fou de nager 48 heures
est quelque chose qu elle jamais été
réalisé par aucun nageur dans le monde
entier il prend le créneau trois mois
plus tard parce que l'entraînement en
fait ne joue plus à ce moment-là le
mental prend le dessus sur ce genre
d'effort donc trois mois plus tard il
est au rendez-vous et pendant quinze
jours de congés son toucher l'eau il
arrive
le jour j et se met à l'eau non je vais
pas vous faire le détail de tout de tout
cette épreuve là et c'est juste que ce
jour là il va nager alors c'est pas ce
jour là ces c'est ce moment là parce que
ça va durer deux jours
il va nager 48 eur 102 km avec un double
record du monde à la clé donc c'était
possible cette histoire de ce petit
garçon de sept adolescents puis de cet
adulte c'est la mienne mais c'est la
vôtre
un jour j'ai décidé d'oublier que
c'était impossible d'oublier que c'était
difficile d'oublier que je ne savais pas
faire et j'ai essayé je me suis entraîné
j'ai pris le temps jusqu'à réussir
je n'ai absolument rien de plus que vous
si moi j'y suis arrivé vous pouvez y
arriver si vous n'avez qu'une seule
chose à retenir de tout ça ça serait la
suivante une citation de mark twain
il ne savait pas que c'était impossible
alors ils l'ont fait oubliez vos limites
oubliez vos barrières
croyez en vous battez vous sans jamais
baisser les bras et vous verrez tout
sera possible
tout deviendra possible l'impossible
n'existe que si vous le rende est
possible alors dans des lieux
impossibles
croyez en vous merci
[Applaudissements]